all right so you mentioned you're down
there in Texas with the border and the
border is our lead story today because
the Secretary of Homeland Security Mr
mycus apparently snapped out of it and
realized wait there's like a gazillion
people flooding into the country and now
they're announcing that there's an
immediate need to build 17 miles of
border wall in Star County Texas because
of illegal entry now this was initially
announced in June it's part of what Joe
Biden though announced in its
inauguration essentially they're ending
the diversion of Border money from
military projects and using actual money
that Congress appropriated for stuff
like this yeah the DHS uh they posted
this announcement and uh outlining just
where this construction would be in Star
County like you said Steve it's part of
a very busy border patrol sector seeing
very high illegal entry 245,000 illegal
entries have been recorded this fiscal
year in the Rio Grand Valley sector and
that contains 21 of these counties so
everyone was shocked when they heard
alejandre mayorcas say this he said
there is presently an acute and
immediate need to construct physical
barriers and roads in the vicinity of
the border of the United States in order
to prevent unlawful entries into the
United States that is a sharp contrast
to the early days of this Administration
uh I think we're missing the whole story
uh this president who got in saying I'm
going to use high-tech and we don't need
a wall I'm going to change these
horrible policies has now found out that
his policies are terrible it has caused
the biggest collapse on Border in
American history and not building the
barrier is not going back to the Viking
age it is actually absolutely necessary
and the thing was last month we found
out there was selling the wall that we
paid for as taxpayers for pennies on the
dollar because the Senate was beginning
to move on forcing the construction of
that wall now mayorcas is admitting he's
building just 20 miles of that wall just
20 miles
so that's going to be in Desperate areas
of Texas Eagle Pass area but it should
be 500 Miles here's what he said yeah
listen look at all that all the that
that uh wall that should be standing
helping our border patrol and our
country instead on pure political for
Pure political reasons he's selling it
off in order not to be forced to build
it here's what he said in 2020 remember
on um Build That Wall are you willing to
tear that wall down
no I'm there will not be another foot of
Wall constructed on my
Administration Lawrence totally wrong
now he's got to build it he's got a
secretary of state of Mexico City he's
got two Mayors scrambling there he's got
Democratic Governors criticizing him he
has no
choice so Brian that was doing campaign
season now we're at another campaign
season and now because it's become an
election issue they're all ing their
position on it 20 uh uh miles of wall is
a joke in the state of Texas do they
know the terrain that we have here on
the border um it's clear that the
president has not visited the Border
because he would know that if they only
put 20 miles there that the cartel is
only going to uh redirect the migrants
to go to a different direction so again
I I think it is for appearance only to
show hey I am trying to do something but
at the end of the day 20 miles a border
is not going to solve the crisis that's
at the southern border why does he not
answer why why wouldn't he sell the
information as well as all the
technology as well as all the border
fencing to the state of Texas when we
tried to buy it when it had already been
paid for by us taxpayers so again this
has been not only been a president that
has been asleep at the wheel on this
issue but he's been quite divisive as
well when Texas tried to do the security
ourselves and this is a little too late
right Lawrence I mean this guy we've
already Millions ions and millions have
come through come over the Border in the
last three years since he's been
president he can't take those millions
and no telling where they are they're in
our country this is too late he should
have done this in the very beginning iny
they're right out there they are they're
sleeping right outside in front of all
these hotels here Lawrence and that's
what Trump said Trump told Fox News
digital he said Biden sees our country
is being invaded what is he going to do
about the 15 million people from prisons
from mental institutions insane asylums
and terrorists that have already come
into our country you know and and
Lawrence I think you have hit the nail
on the head and that is it's all about
politics and right now you know there
are Democrats who are uh Governors and
Mayors and they are pounding this
Administration to do something and in
particular the Republicans have been
very effective talking about the amount
of fenel coming into the country there
must be something about that particular
area in Star County where a lot of if I
had to guess and we don't have this
information I'm just speculating if I
had to guess that's where a lot of fenel
comes through and so Joe Biden who's
going to be on the campaign Trail
through for the next year and a couple
of months he needs to say you know what
we put up the wall where the fenel was
coming in and I've reduced the rate
because he he he needs uh some talking
points because right now when we roll
the video and all the channels are
rolling the video of the migration wave
Joe looks bad because the fenel is
coming in and killing people but they
say it comes through ports of Entry
number one number two is that that's
what they claim number number two is you
can't tell everyone walls don't work run
on it have your whole party prevent
Trump from doing it including strangling
Paul Ryan saying we won't pass the
budget unless you only agree to $1.4
billion and then turn around and say one
mile of w work unless you're going to
look into the camera and say I was wrong
I was wrong about what would be
effective at the border and I'm looking
to uh amend that also he's taken on the
environmental groups evidently he's
suspending 26 environmental laws La in
order to build that so his
environmentalists are now mad at him and
the Horny Toad or whatever grasshopper
will no longer will be affected or a
cactus won't be able to spry up uh to
spring up in the desert yeah or yeah who
knows not many of those there yeah we
we'll see what's going on so this in
California this is just symbolically
shows another reason why Trump is
continuing to gain momentum it's not
something he said it's what he did that
turns out to be right long
Brian Brian to your point and I think
it's an excellent point people aren't
going to believe that when they see kids
in their communities all over not just
Texas but all over the country dropping
dead because of the th how can you sell
something that isn't working I I I know
the White House has this thing that it's
all about image but when you see the
folks that are actually dropping dead in
the communities when you see the child
trafficking rinks that are being
advertised everywhere even here in the
state of Texas when you see the migrants
that are being camped out in communities
from Chicago to Philly to New York City
Texas has been overrun all our shelters
have been overrun so again the pantries
have been emptied um the visuals just
tell a different story here they do
indeed now Lawrence uh we're going to
talk a little bit about politics and uh
we're going to come back to you in a
minute and you're going to talk to the
folks there including your mother who
during the next couple of minutes going
to tell you how you did in the first uh
10 minutes of the show
okay y thanks family all right thank you
Lawrence yeah go check with the diners
looking forward to hearing what they
have to say in the great city of Dallas
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian kilme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis